to the organizers for
inviting me so i'm going to talk about
uh
how one can design fast spectral
algorithms
using a very classical area in analysis
called approximation theory
so let me let me mention that this is
uh based on a monograph with sushant
says deva
who's right now a postdoc of dan
and let me tell you very quickly what
the goal would be
so uh the starting point is
that many algorithms as you probably
have seen in the workshop so far
rely on our ability to compute
approximations to certain matrix
function
times vectors okay so the kind of things
that probably you have seen
are when when you could solve a system
of equations
uh in particular when a is a graph
laplacian
then this this primitive has been used
quite a lot already and
as you all know another primitive that
a couple of talks mention is
this matrix exponential times a vector
so again if a is a graph laplacian then
this corresponds to
what is called the heat kernel
and and it corresponds to the continuous
time random walk
in the graph and uh i mean these
probably
are very basic uh uh things that one
like one would like to compute
and here again if you want to keep in
mind you can think of a as the
random walk matrix of a graph and all
this does is computes the distribution
after s steps so if you start with some
charges on vertices
then a to the s computes the
distribution of these charges after s
steps
and among other applications of these
methods are uh
to sparse cut and other cut problems
where
the algorithms look at the top
eigenvectors and eigen values of this
graph
so we would like to understand
how to speed these things up speed these
computations up
and uh the main kind of message of this
talk would be
uh that very often one could reduce the
number of
so one could reduce these problems to a
computation
where all you are doing is doing matrix
vector multiplications
and another small number of times
okay so the matrix that often shows up
is not necessarily the matrix that you
start with
but quite often it is the same matrix
and in particular
uh if you could compute
matrix vector products with for a then
you can also do that typically with the
kind of matrices b that arrive here
so this makes them very attractive for
algorithm design because then you
essentially reduce the problems
to the number of these calls times
times the sparsity or the time it takes
to multiply the given matrix
to a vector and not only are these
theoretically nice practically
uh you know when when data is stored
outside
these are these are really uh these
these result in really fast
methods and
so so this this talk would would go
through
trying to understand these reductions uh
by a classical area analysis called
approximation theory
and it turns out that often this is the
right framework to study the complexity
of these how how much can you speed
these things up
so so let me let me remind you of uh of
this area
so imagine that you're given a function
uh which is let's say continuous
and uh what you would like
what you're also given is an interval so
you're given an interval and a function
and what you would like is to find an
approximation to this function
in this interval okay so for instance
here is this red curve which is the
function and the green curve is a
polynomial
it could be a polynomial which is trying
to approximate this uh
this function uh in the interval now
here uh there could be many notions of
approximations but one could think of
and uh the the notion of approximation
that we would like
is uh the
uh infinity uh so so i'll
i'll define a word for it in a minute
but let me explain what is the quantity
that we are trying to control
the quantity that we want to control is
that this green curve
is close to the red curve at every point
in the interval so you want to minimize
the largest the the maximum distance
between these two curves
so this is a infinity uh infinity
version of
uh measuring distances one could also
ask for approximations
uh in the l2 sense where you're just
minimizing the average distance
but as it will turn out that this is the
right notion for us
so so this is uh this is what you know
analysts have been trying to do over
hundreds of years let me formalize it a
little bit
and also talk about what is uh what are
we looking for
in this uh in this green curve i mean
till now you know we haven't really said
anything about
uh why are we doing this so uh
what we would like to what we would like
to uh
uh what we'd like to have in this uh in
this green curve or
or this uh function which is which we
are using to approximate the
given function is that
it is simple and and by simple i mean
for this talk it could be a low degree
polynomial or a low degree rational
function
okay so
uh such approximations are called
uniform approximations and these were
uh this this this line of research this
area was started by a chebyshev
more than 150 years ago and
they they ask for approximations of
given functions by
polynomials when the degree is specified
so sigma d
is just a set of all polynomials of
degree at most d
and when you're looking at the the
supremum of the error
over the entire interval
okay and similarly uh
the quality uh you know the quantity
that we want to measure for a rational
function
is the degree of uh
the larger of p and q so p and q are
both polynomials
and the the cost that we will associate
to it is the larger of the degree
so chebyshev actually started this area
in trying to improve the design
for the steam engine which was given by
james watt
and and there the notion of universal
uniform approximation came up very
naturally
and since then it has many many
applications in many areas of
mathematics and engineering
i'm not going to talk about it instead i
would bring your focus to the kind of
functions that we are really interested
in
so going back to the first slide where i
talked about
the matrix functions these are the
corresponding
scalar functions that we would be
interested in so for instance
you could think of a function which is
just the simplest
possible function probably a monomial so
s is a positive integer
and you want to understand
approximations to x to the s
or the function e to the minus x
or the function one by x and each of
these three functions will play a role
in trying to develop fast algorithms for
the three problems i mentioned in the
first slide
and the kind of intervals that we would
be interested in would be different for
these three functions
uh so for x to the s typically we would
be interested in approximating it in
in minus 1 1 e to the minus x
in some interval which grows uh you know
think of
n as a parameter which will grow so some
0 to n
and 1 by x in the interval 0 to infinity
and for many of our applications just uh
you know
good enough approximations will suffice
and we'll talk more about it
let's go back to let's go back to the
matrix world and see how these things
can actually help us
so as a simple example we look at
computing
a to the s times v where a is a
symmetric matrix
and all eigen values are in minus 1 1.
so this you can actually ensure by
scaling so this is not a major
major restriction uh
so this absolutely straightforward way
to compute this uh
uh well probably depends who you ask but
i mean some people will actually try to
compute this matrix but
but i mean the next level would be to
you just multiply the vector
with the matrix a again and again until
you get this
this thing and this takes times order m
times s
okay where m is the number of nonzero
entries in a
or in particular the time it takes you
could replace m by
the time it takes to multiply a with a
vector
so often the matrix doesn't have to be
sparse and still you could uh
you know you could you could compute
these things faster so so that's what
you would
like to think of now suppose uh this
this very basic function x to the s
can be approximated up to an error of
delta
over the entire interval by some
polynomial
which has degree d okay so d is the
degree of the polynomial
uh and the polynomial has this form so
it is
it is given to you as uh as a bunch of
coefficients
well i mean if you're seeing these
things for the first time you would you
would say okay this is not possible i
mean this
this is as simple as it gets how can you
how can you
reduce the degree here right but notice
that we are we are allowing for some
error
so it's not going to be uh it's not
going to be something
that you know uh so so yeah
so i mean difficult to prove lower
bounds here and
so so we'll come to what what we can do
with respect to the polynomial but
suppose you have such a polynomial and d
uh
of degree d then the natural candidate
approximation
for computing this quantity would be to
just
plug this uh matrix in this
polynomial and just multiply it with the
vector v
okay this is
uh what you would do this is a you know
this is just a
formal replacement of a scalar by a
matrix
and now again you can check that the
time to compute this quantity
is uh order m times d where m
is the time it takes to compute one
matrix vector multiplication
with a and d is the degree of your
approximant
okay so so this is why we chose d
this is why we chose that to optimize on
the degree when we were looking for
approximating uh this monomial
so why uh so why is this a good
approximation
okay this is where we will see why the
notion of uniform approximation is the
right one so let's try to understand or
analyze
the error between what we gave as a
candidate
to this quantity so this is what we
suggested
is what you should use as an
approximation to a to the s times v
so imagine v is a v is a unit vector
okay so if i
if i want to bound this it is sufficient
to so you can write v in
in an eigenvector basis in an
orthonormal basis and it is sufficient
to
bound this error for every element of
that basis
okay so a is symmetric so the basis of
choice would be the eigenvector basis
for a
which is orthonormal and the moment i
plug in
the moment i plug in uh an eigenvector
here
this inequality
is nothing but querying this polynomial
at that particular eigenvalue of the
matrix
right we know that these matrices are
simultaneously diagonalizable so if i
plug in an eigenvector here
what i'm going to get is lambda to the s
and lambda
summation ai lambda to lambda lambda
lambda
uh lambda to the iai
okay but and this is where uh we use
this property that
while we don't know exactly the
eigenvalues of a we do know
that they they are in this range minus
one to one
so and but our approximation
was close uh in the entire range
right so if if somehow you knew where
the eigen values of a lied
then you could use this to get a good
approximation to this quantity
okay so this by a simple diagonalization
argument for symmetric matrices
you are able to you are able to reduce
the matrix problem to a scalar problem
so symmetry will be important here
and the and the closeness that you get
is uh
from the from the guarantee that this
polynomial
uh is close to the monomial
so now let's come back to the the real
question uh how small can
d be for those of
who who have not seen this any guesses
i mean it depends on telescopes
you guessed it right that time yeah want
it to be log one over delta
that would be amazing no but i mean you
know that
that's that's really where uh yeah that
that would be amazing
but uh uh but but you know if you
it depends uh you know if you i mean
i've asked this question to many people
and some people say d will be
uh s you can't you can't do better than
and some people just said equal to
constant so there is a wide variety of
optimism or pessimism that you can
imagine so it turns out
yeah i mean ravi is right it depends
upon delta of course
and it it turns out the uh
one answer to this question is square
root of s if i'm willing to kind of
suppress the log one over delta term
right now
then the answer is square root of s
okay and
so the theorem is that for any integer s
any positive integer s and for any delta
if i pick my degree to be square root s
times log one over delta
then uh there is a polynomial of degree
d
which approximates the monomial x to the
s within delta over the range minus 1 1.
so this this result
can explain many things actually which
which
some of which you may know some of which
you may not know so for instance
so so going back to simulating random
walks right so imagine you are given a
probability distribution starting
probability distribution
and you want to understand the s-step
distribution so you could do that now in
m square root as time
okay as long as you're happy with some
approximate answer there is a famous uh
method to solve linear system of
equations called the conjugate gradient
method
uh if all the if all the if all the
eigenvalues of this matrix a
are in the interval 0 1 which in
particular means it's symmetric and
positive semi-definite
positive definite then you can recover a
very good solution to this
in time which is roughly the time it
takes to do a matrix vector
multiplication with a times square root
of the condition number so the square
root comes out exactly because of this
approximation
similarly you could go back to your
method to use
compute eigenvectors so the most popular
method is the so called power method
and you could again speed it up so
typical typically you would
never output the largest eigenvalue you
would output
some approximation to it so if if if
you're happy with the
a number between uh you know which is
at at least one minus delta times the
largest eigenvalue
then then you can again bring it down to
m over root delta
so the traditional analysis of power
method gets you m over delta
okay so these are three important
results i'm not going to talk about them
i would rather focus uh on showing you
uh uh how to get such a polynomial
because this is probably what uh you
would not normally see these methods you
know you probably know in some form or
the other you may not have seen them
you know as a more or less a direct
corollary of these
this approximation so the central player
here is
uh the chebyshev polynomials so there
are many kinds of chebyshev polynomials
i'm going to focus on
a certain kinds of chebyshev polynomials
which can be recursively defined
in the following way so a chebyshev
polynomial is defined for every degree
so the the constant chebyshev polynomial
is really just one
the degree 1 chebyshev polynomial is x
and subsequently you can define them
recursively
by this formula so
one way to parse this formula is the
following
that they have this averaging property
okay which says that if i look at
the chebyshev polynomial of degree d
then it arises essentially
by taking an average of the two
neighboring chebyshev polynomials
and dividing it by 1 by x so you you
pick up a
factor of x in this process
okay i mean this just follows directly
from this i just shifted this term here
and divided it by two
and i just call uh d d minus one and d
minus two different things
so for for people uh uh uh who have seen
trigonometric polynomials another way to
define
which is an equivalent way to define
chebyshev polynomials
is that these are exactly the
polynomials which will arise
when you try to write down cos d theta
as a polynomial in cos theta
okay so we all know that cos 2 theta is
2 cos square
theta minus 1 right am i right
so the chebyshev polynomial is
corresponds to 2x squared minus 1. so in
particular this also implies a certain
boundedness property of these chebyshev
polynomials
that they remain bounded in the interval
minus 1 1.
this is important
okay i mean this can be proved directly
as well but this is the cleanest way to
see this
okay so let's get back to uh let's get
back to approximating the monomial
so here comes uh here comes a
probabilistic experiment
uh so we will which will do so imagine
you
uh so remember this s is the same as
which appears in the monomial that we
are trying to approximate
so so let's imagine picking iid
random variables so identically and
independently distributed
which are plus 1 and minus 1 with
probability half
and let d d sub s
be the sum of these y i's so another way
to think of what d sub
s is is that imagine you start a random
walk
on a line of integers at zero
and then with probability half you go
right and with probability half you go
left
so d sub s is your uh
unsigned distance from the origin
okay yeah right i mean this is
sine distance sorry and that's what i
meant yeah sign distance yeah
so uh uh a basic uh you know chair no
bound argument
immediately implies that if you if you
do this
then uh you are not very far from the
origin right your distance from the
origin is not much more than
uh square root s right and now
exactly you can get the dependency on
delta as well
so this is this is a tight result and
can be proved easily by
a chain of bound argument
okay
so to relate this uh uh this
probabilistic
uh process with uh with uh with
with the chebyshev polynomials
uh here is a simple observation okay
it's an equality it says that imagine
doing the following that you you
you toss these coins and then you see
where you are you look at the sign
distance
and you pick up that chebyshev
polynomial corresponding to the sign
distance now i haven't defined chebyshev
polynomials for negative integers but
you could just define them to be
that for the positive integers so it's
so t of minus d you could just define to
be t of d
okay so if you do that
and you look at the expected polynomial
then you recover exactly the monomial
x to the s okay
so here's the proof it's my induction
okay it's really short
uh so the base case i will not do
let me do the uh uh and let me do the
uh inductive part
so so let's look at x to the s plus one
so i'll pull out one x from it and use
induction to write
x to the s as an expectation over these
chebyshev polynomials
and now i can pull x in
and use that i identity that they
satisfy this averaging property which i
mentioned in the
in the in the previous slide so now i
can write down
tds x times cds as the average of
tds plus 1 and tds minus 1. so notice
that this plus 1 is not with
s but it's with this random variable ds
so
with prob so but that is exactly the
definition
of uh
tds plus one so where you have chosen
one more random variable
okay this is uh this inequalities are
always simple right so
it's inequalities where we have to worry
about
uh so so here is an approximation to x
to the s
which now is rather natural that
just define the polynomial uh to be
uh uh the following polynomial so what
does this polynomial say
what what is this you know what does
this quantity say that you again
do a s-step random walk you look at
where you are
and only if you are at most a distance d
you output this polynomial otherwise you
just output zero
so you're cutting off the tail of this
probability distribution
okay and the choice of d is exactly what
was dictated by that where basically it
doesn't really matter when you can cut
it off
okay yeah
and the proof that this is a good
approximation is also
rather straightforward so let's try to
understand
the the maximum error in the interval
minus 1
1 of our polynomial and x to the s
so the way it is defined
if i if i remove this term then i know
that this is x to the s
this this expectation so the difference
of
psd x and x to the s
what you recover is the complementary
event that what is the
the event that the distance is larger
than d
right so i'm just taking the difference
of these two polynomials using linearity
of expectation
so what i get is exactly this event
and now i use the fact that these
chebyshev polynomials are bounded in
minus 1
1 by 1. so i can get rid of this thing
completely and so what i'm remain with
is the expectation
that i go a distance more than d
of this event but this is exactly the
probability that i
that i go out distance farther than d
but that by our choice of s is at most
delta
okay so we crucially used the
boundedness property of the chebyshev
polynomials here
this looks uh very simple right
and and
it's it's i mean yeah it's kind of hard
to imagine that this sits at
some of the most uh useful numerical and
spectral methods that we use today
okay so uh so now can we
i mean what have we learned from this
method so what we have learned first of
all
is that our intuition about how to
approximate functions
could be often wrong because our first
first intent
to when we are given a function to
approximate is is to
compute its taylor expansion and
truncate it at some point
okay so suppose you are a compulsive
taylor expander right so but you could
still do the following
so you you compute your taylor series
which which
which is nothing but a polynomial which
you know so there are there are there
are these monomials in there
just replace each monomial by this
corresponding polynomial that we just
computed
not by the chebychev polynomial by the
following the polynomial
yes because you know it's in some sense
you have a function which is the sum of
functions so i'm approximating each
function
which in our case was just the monomial
right and you actually can get a
quadratic
improvement in in the case when the when
the when the taylor series uh
decays quite rapidly so one such
function for which
you can you can get an approximation is
the
exponential
so you could do this you could you know
we all know how to expand e to the minus
x in taylor series you know it's 1 minus
x plus x square by 2 factorial minus x
cubed by 3 factorial
so just go through these series up to a
point that you like
and just replace each of these x to the
i by
the p i that i the corresponding pi
and actually this works okay
this does give you a degree which is
quadratically better than what probably
taylor's
taylor expansion can give you
okay so you get this b versus square
root b gap
we're saying the taylor series if we
take degree oh to get cons
to get constant delta we would get
degree b or
yeah okay i mean you could i mean
in applications in tcs you would require
delta to be one over polynomial in n
so you will pick up some log factors
yeah
how is this different from just uh doing
the
usual chebyshev approximation right off
the bat uh what is the chebyshev
approximation
you know you like use the roots of the
chemistry of polynomials to tell you
what points to sample from your function
and then you interpret
interpolate by like legendre i think
that is the l2 approximation
yeah so we so infinity is a rather
difficult uh
problem you know that's actually our one
most optimal infinitive
yeah so under certain conditions you can
show that you can derive infinity
approximations from l2 approximations
it's but it's not true university yeah
but i mean okay so these are these are
results which exist right i mean this is
not
anything uh anything new right this is
just a reinterpretation of
many of these classical results so can
you apply to yourself
i mean like keep applying it again
that's great i mean that's uh
uh no it doesn't because that's the next
slide
yeah so i mean you know it's
so we can handle the coefficients as
well so that is not the
issue but it doesn't work so there is a
fundamental limit to this process
yeah and i'll come to that but but let
me also i mean i think i slipped one
thing that this is the same square root
uh
uh improvement that you get in the
grower search uh
in in quantum right so people who are
familiar with quantum
and this is exactly i mean you can prove
grover search and
also in this framework i'm not going to
do that
but uh since our motivation was things
like solving semi-definite programs
and this multiplicative weight update
method of aurora and kali
required us to compute things like
you know a matrix exponential times a
vector this does give
improvements on running time for many
semi-defined programming algorithms
okay and in particular with lorenzo and
sushant
in 2012 we proved not exactly via this
way but
a related manner that you could you
could you could solve the
graph partitioning problem of balance
separator in time which runs in m over
root gamma
where gamma is the target conductance
that you're looking at so this
this is an improvement and a similar
result was gotten by
uh
ul perez using very fancy technology of
evolving sets
and this is very simple
okay so so so then comes
gary's question right why how far can
all this take us
so actually not very far so uh we can
show
again you know this uh probably many of
these things are
known known somewhere in the literature
it's 150 year old literature it's
not easy to figure out what was known
and what was not
but that aside you can show that you
can't improve on these square roots
so i mean i'll give you two illustrative
examples that this monomial bound that i
showed you can't be really improved
beyond square root s and if you wanted
to approximate the exponential
on 0 to b then you can't get better than
and and actually the proof of this
relies on a very interesting uh theorem
from approximation theory called marco's
theorem so this is not the same mark of
uh neither it's the same markov neither
is the difficulty in the proof at all
the same so
this is a much harder theorem to prove
uh i think
it was the brother of the markov that we
know
and more interestingly this was inspired
by a problem that mendeleev who invented
the periodic table
actually suggested to uh to
one of his colleagues and the theorem
says the following
it's a it's a it's an extreme statement
which says that
if you have a degree d polynomial which
is bounded by 1 in the interval minus 1
1 then its derivative cannot become
arbitrarily high
the derivative is at most a d square
okay this this theorem almost
immediately implies these
these lower bounds and actually
chebyshev polynomials are the tight
examples for this
for this statement and actually you can
you can you can also consider
higher derivative versions of this of
this result and again chebyshev
polynomials
uh are optimal for that
so how do we go beyond this so there was
a reason why i introduced rational
approximations in the beginning
that we we go beyond the world of
polynomials and into the
rather mysterious world of rational
functions
okay let's see and and now ravi's wishes
will start coming true
okay so here is a here is the result
uh which says that if you have
we go back to and so from now on we
focus on the exponential function
uh so so if i look at this exponential
function e to the minus x
and i want to approximate it by a
rational function so in particular
uh it is just one over a polynomial of
degree d
over the entire interval zero to
infinity
i can get an error of at most 2 to the
minus d
okay such a result cannot hold for
polynomials
polynomials blow up to infinity or minus
infinity as
as as x goes to infinity or minus
infinity
okay but the moment you allow me
rational functions
i can get amazing results so now for
instance if i want delta error
uh the degree log one over delta
suffices
and and the polynomial is uh actually
maybe a diehard taylor expander will
again discover it we do nothing
but just flip the function take its
taylor series
and flip the taylor series okay that's
all i've done here
so this is really the taylor taylor
polynomial of degree d corresponding to
the function e to the x
and i just look at the inverse so this
actually works
this could be a nice uh mathematic
problem that this works
and the proof is a clever inductive
hypothesis
i'm not going to go into that but i'll
just bring your attention to the
to the fact that there is absolutely no
dependence on the length of the interval
here
so the length of the interval in our
theory settings you know and algorithm
settings correspond to the norm of the
matrices that we are looking at so we
work with positive semi-definite
matrices
so the length of the interval
corresponds to the the norm
you know so from 0 to the norm of the
matrix and this can be rather large
so we are getting things which are
independent of the norm
so uh so i guess i already said this
that
when in in in theory applications delta
is about one over poly n so log n
degree suffices order log and degree
surfaces
well however there is a uh
yeah so this is your guess for you know
so if you wanted to compute this
you you could try computing this okay
but this is a big problem how do we
compute this
uh so now we are in this world where
we have reduced the problem to computing
inverses well that was coming right the
moment you saw rational functions
you should have known that we would have
to resort to matrix inversion
right but but you know for
for this audience it should not be a big
surprise
that there are fantastic results which
do inversion
in near linear time right so there is
some hope
right and that hope at least when
these matrices have a
nice structure you would hope that you
could invoke some of these laplacian
solvers or sgd solvers
to be able to do this right and really
get a
m login type of an algorithm for
computing the matrix exponential
so let's see uh
so as i said that you you i mean so we
are we are moving towards trying to
understand to what extent we can invoke
the laplacian or sd technology
in these calculations so uh
so what what becomes natural is to
understand uh the eigenvalues of this
matrix and in particular uh the roots of
this
polynomial okay so one thing you could
try to
do is to you look at this polynomial so
it's it's a
it's a polynomial which has a closed
form and you could factorize it
and instead of com you know instead of
doing the inverse of the whole thing
uh now you have reduced the problem of
inverting this and then taking products
right so factorization helped us
simplify the problem
so since our degree is log n uh uh
we we just need to focus on computing
these things
okay so imagine your matrix a was a
laplacian
or an sdd matrix so then it becomes
uh uh i mean the life would be great
if all these beta i's are negative
because if these are negative then they
only improve their sddness
right and then i could invoke these
laplacian solvers and
at least for a large class of settings
be done with it however
there is a problem
so for this polynomial uh the roots are
extremely well studied
and life is not as easy so in fact you
can show all kinds of results about the
roots of this polynomial
i mean i don't want to go too much into
it but i can just tell you that
you know there are you you can try to
wriggle your way around
it doesn't work okay so there are many
arguments that you could give or
many simple modifications that you could
try to do it doesn't work
okay and you could think about it it's
not too difficult
what would be nice however is if i could
instead of starting with this
taylor approximation so once again
taylor approximation fails us
if if you could come up with an
approximation where the holes are
whether the roots of that thing in the
denominator
or the poles of these rational functions
are all negative
because that's exactly the property that
we are looking at
so this leads us into the world of
trying to understand rational
rational approximations where we have
restrictions on the roots
okay so so already rational
approximations are
uh difficult things to deal with
uh and now we we want to be more
ambitious that we want
uh conditions on the roots okay
but how about this uh you know so
a smart undergrad if you give them this
problem you say you know you just don't
know enough analysis
i know that 1 plus x by d to the minus d
converges to
e to the minus x and it has this
property that all roots are negative
so why not use this
can anyone tell me why
okay so the the short answer is that it
doesn't converge fast enough
you can show that uh the convergence is
slow
okay and i mean in particular at x equal
to one the
error is quite large
in fact you can even show something much
stronger that
as long as you have one over a
polynomial
you can't really do anything you you
your error will be
at least one over d square
okay so now what
i can only guess you have to put
something on top now yeah
or or the next simple thing works just
try to find a polynomial of this thing
which is the same as putting something
on the top
so rather than looking at this guy here
uh you look at a polynomial of of of
this one plus
x by d and this actually works
so this has all the properties that you
need
except uh we don't know what the
coefficients of this polynomial
are because this is proved by a
uh uh some kind of a you know
a convoluted existential type argument
how did you find this reference sorry
how did you find this reference so
that's actually interesting story i will
tell you
so there was a paper by arora and kale
which claimed this result
actually but i don't want to this talk
is being recorded so
i don't want to get in trouble yeah okay
so uh so so the coefficients uh is not
really a problem
uh so we went through a proof of this
simplified some parts and we could we
could get
we could get a reasonable bound on the
coefficients
uh which actually works
i mean you don't have to worry about
these numbers precisely this remember
that d will be like logarithmic so these
numbers are all small
okay in the eventual applications
however in in a couple of years ago with
lorenzo
we actually got a similar statement
without knowing the
without knowing the coefficients so
there is yet another method called lan
church method which i'm not going to
talk about
but there is a way to get a good
you know there is a way to extend just
the existence guarantee of these
approximations
to uh two algorithms without knowing the
coefficients it's much more hard work
and that's what we had to do because at
that point we did not uh we were not
able to
uh figure out what the coefficients are
so so in particular we
so this is one of the main corollaries
of this uh of this
line of argument which says that
for sdd matrices you could you could
compute
a very good approximations to the
x minus a times a vector v in time
which really depends very minimally on
the norm of a
so the key point is to to note that the
dependence on the norm is
log as opposed to square root
or trivially just the norm okay okay
and for for applications so
semi-definite programming uh these
numbers the norms are bounded by
polynomials so this this number is
really some logarithmic
but all this was made possible by uh by
using
uh the the spielmann tang
sed solvers and the
and the great result of uh uh soft sean
hagenberger
as a corollary you could get for
instance a linear time algorithm for
for graph partitioning problem so before
i
showed a result where the dependence on
the on the
so there was a gamma so it was m by root
gamma
and now we could just even get rid of
root comma
and and this is uh this is ud solvers
that we used
okay uh
so so once you have such a result which
uses such heavy machinery like the
laplacian solvers
uh the first question is are these
things really necessary are we being
silly
right i mean just because we can do this
are we doing this or
there is some in really an inherent
reason
to uh uh well at that time when we were
writing the paper we were in a hurry
so we didn't care but after we were
worried right that maybe someone will
say oh you don't need all this stuff
maybe there is a
maybe there is a direct way to do all
this stuff
and the answer turns out that it is
required
so so there is a way to go the other way
around
that if someone claims that they have uh
the ability to compute matrix
exponentials
in the way this theorem guarantees
which depends on the norm
logarithmically
let's say then i could use this thing as
a black box
to to obtain
an inverter a laplacian solver
okay so this is a rather uh
uh symbol full statement i would like to
bring your attention to
two things that uh so one is
so so one is that the met you you assume
essentially that the condition number of
the matrix is one by epsilon this is
what this thing is saying
and then there is an error parameter
delta
so one could write a inverse as
essentially a sum of matrix exponentials
where the number of terms in this
is poly logarithmic in one over epsilon
delta so the log is very important
okay this log essentially implies that
the number of calls to the exponential
solver when you want to
do laplacian solving uh would be
uh would be a polylogarithmic
and the weights are not too large so
they the error can be controlled
i mean because each so i mean this this
suggests a a
straightforward way to compute an
approximation to a inverse times a
vector which is just compute this
quantity here
right and but you know the errors will
get multiplied by the weight so you have
to worry about how big the weights can
be
but the weights are not so large
so this works out i mean if you could do
this then this works out
and uh uh the proof of this actually
is uh somewhat complex and i would i
mean i would
you know i would encourage someone to
try to come up with a simpler
simpler reason for this but let me point
out that naively what you would try to
do
is uh use this identity
which is this is a basic identity which
says that if you look at the function e
to the minus x t
dt where t is the variable and you
integrate it from 0 to infinity you get
1 by x
so we again go back to the scalar world
okay and our hope would be that
if somehow we could discretize this
integral this is an integral after all
integral is nothing but a limit of some
summations right
this symbol is just a limit so you you
could imagine that
if you know if you're allowed to
discretize this thing then you could
just plug in the matrix and get a
spectral approximation to a inverse
using these things
so the straightforward discretization
where you just
chop zero to infinity uniformly
doesn't work okay it will require
a rather large number of
terms which is unacceptable
geometrically right
yes so so the next thing actually works
uh
which is uh to
just to make this you know to make this
geometric uh substitution
and then do the uniform discretization
in this so first you
you you elongate the space by
uh exponentially and then then you you
do it
however the proof is actually quite
complex
it uses a whole bunch of results from
analysis uh
in particular the euler maclaurin
formula uh which
which requires us to to to to control
uh very high derivatives of this object
and in particular also uses uh
certain estimates that come from the
riemann zeta function
and i would like to point out this is i
mean for people who have never seen a
euler maclaurin formula and how it
actually works
uh this is really i mean given that it
was discovered
maybe more than 150 200 years ago
it's really uh one of the only methods i
know which does a global error analysis
so you know so that the traditional
strategy when you do things like this
is to you have a
you have a you have a function whose
integral you are trying to calculate
you chopped it up and then
you you know you you could do something
like this you could approximate these by
rectangles
and then say okay upper bound the error
here upper bound the other hair upper
bound the error here and so on that's
what
uh you know one way to do would be right
but that all that doesn't work i mean so
so so the euler mclaren formula actually
captures
uh cancellations up to uh up to gear
derivatives
and in that sense it's really a very
global analysis
and and but but as
a result it requires you to be able to
understand very high derivatives of the
function
okay so but you could also view that sum
is
some funny combination of the you know
in the eigen space or the eigenvalues
right the eigen functions
i mean because you know what the e to
the t a
yeah yeah but that's
exactly that's what we're doing right so
so we prove the result in the scalar
world and then immediately by
diagonalization move it move it up
but one point to note is
that this is this does not require your
matrix to be
sdd this works for any positive definite
matrix
okay and hence it suggests the following
heuristic
uh solver for positive definite matrix
okay so
so this is a this is uh we don't know
how to do this
fast enough i guess the best method i
know
is by a conjugate gradient so so
recall that your goal is to you're given
a positive definite matrix a
and your goal is to solve the system for
the vector u so you want to compute a
inverse times u
so here is what you could try to do okay
this
this this slide i must warn you is more
speculative
so you know take everything with a
grain of salt so suppose you could write
the matrix
a as a sum of
k matrices which are in some sense
simpler so if you really want to have a
concrete picture think of a as a
laplacian
and think of a 1 to a k as laplacians of
trees
in the ground so trees are easier than
solving laplacians right so that's what
we
maybe you can think about so
when i do this uh it immediately i mean
by definition e to
the minus t a is e to the minus t times
the sum of these guys
okay nothing really happened
now suppose magic happens and
k is small and computing these guys
which let's say going back to our
analogy with laplacian this is nothing
but the exponential
of the of the laplacian of a tree
okay times v is easier easier than
computing
e to the minus a times v
and also uh uh let's say some
something like this holds this kind of
inequality this kind of uh
approximation definitely holds in the
scalar world so let's for a moment
assume that this kind of
uh thing holds in in the matrix world as
well
that you can you can write this matrix
exponential as a product of these
matrices
okay that's can be fair far off right i
mean
yeah so that's where there is a
heuristic for solving so i i will come
to it yeah
well that's true it's under trace it's
true no no no no he's right
so we come to that okay so so we
we we come to that so so so right now we
are dreaming right it's like the last
five minutes of the talk
we are allowed to we are tired and we
are dreaming and
so so then uh you could just write down
the following
following approximation which is
so you use the theorem from the previous
slide
okay which told you that a a inverse for
any positive definite a
could be written as a sum of uh
so the theorem said that a inverse is
approximate
can be approximated by
by this thing
but then all we have done is uh opened
up each of these e to the minus
t j a which was
a one to a k and then we use this
approximation
okay and this gives us this
approximation to to n inverse
okay so so as uh a couple of uh more
than a couple of people have observed
that this uh the the problem here is the
thing in the red
really everything else maybe you are but
this is just wrong
okay and this all graduate students
should know or even undergraduate
students should know
that this holds only when all the
matrices commute together but
this is a bit too much to hope for to
find a decomposition where all the
matrices commute
okay so what ravi said was this uh trace
thing
uh so a version of this thing holds if
you apply trace here but then you get an
inequality
didn't somebody mentioned formula or
least product i'm coming to that that
actually
golden ravi man golden thompson but
golden thumbs and also ravi uh
let me remind that it holds only for two
matrices
and there are classic wrong papers that
appeared in stalker fox which
used it for three matrices
okay so but but as gary said right so
so there is a there is a theorem here
which is this uh the product formula
uh from uh from uh i think from physics
or something like that
i don't i don't know but what it says is
that this is immorally true
okay that you could you you could take
your exponential
and you just slow down the process so
you divide this by each of these bis by
b and now you actually write it as a
product
and now you do this thing p times
okay so if instead of
something like this uh to be true uh
if if if approximations of this form i
mean so this is definitely an
approximation to this
this thing that you are trying to do the
question is
how big a p do you need right
and and hence uh a heuristic okay so
it's possible that uh for certain
settings you could get
uh p to be uh yeah there are papers and
quantum competing on hamiltonian
simulation
that have expressions like this but that
converge faster than the lee product
formula
yeah so the naive analysis of lee
product form i mean the naive proof of
this
gives you a pretty bad bound on p you
can get things
not that formula that converge better oh
really yeah
i think i've seen uh i've seen such
results which which look at uh which
expand in terms of this and then the
commutator
you know the the difference between the
the
commuting and the anti-commuting terms
right but but yeah this is just
food for thought for you know to think
about
i mean probably this will not work but i
think it will be good to kind of rule it
out firmly
okay very quick question yeah so i mean
one other thing you could do you know
sankey's i mean another way to
express and was you take the
characteristic polynomial
and you get n times which is large right
but then you
take your approximations and replace pi
so somehow with root n power
you should be able to do inverses right
yeah but the root n we can conjugate
gradient already implies root n so
beating root n is a the main problem
here right
yeah so root and we can do right but
beating root n is really
uh that's what we want to do nothing is
already known for psp i mean
you have
related to the condition number if you
don't have the condition number still
depends on the dimension not the square
root
and the problem with just taking the
characteristic polynomial and then
substituting in your approximations is
that would only work if like all the
coefficients were positive or decreasing
or you need
otherwise you can have issues with the
cancellation
like if you just approximate each
coefficient that is i mean the each term
that's not good because they have
cancellation in them i
think that's the issue oh i think you're
right only monomials are approximately
this right when you put coefficients you
better right
yeah yeah okay so that's all i have to
say about uh
all this stuff let me conclude uh by
by just you know reminding you what
happened so
so we looked at this uniform or
chebyshev notion of approximation this
turns out to be the right notion
for the kind of algorithmic applications
to design spectral or numerical
algorithms that
are currently you know in the in the in
the middle of
revolutionizing fast algorithms and
uh one take home is that taylor series
is often not the best you know in case
you encounter
a matrix functional like the logarithmic
or
you know something like that that this
is not the best thing that you should do
and uh as i said that uh
even many times uh
you know even if you just know the
existence of good approximations
it's often enough uh for
for making these results work by
combining it with what is called the
land charge method
so well as far as rational
approximations are concerned
this is uh i mean this is really
a very bizarre area with with almost no
structure
to it and if you if you like a challenge
problem here is a problem
so we saw that so one interpretation of
this matrix exponential result
is that you could do continuous time
random walks in time which doesn't
depend on time
right that's uh if you wanted to do
a t time continuous random walk
then you could really do it in m times
logarithmically in t
okay because t contributes to the norm
of this matrix
right so we want to do e to the minus t
times the laplacian
so can we get such a result for our
traditional random walk
the answer is i don't know and i think
this uh this
this requires you to unders or solve
some approximation theory problem
which i don't know how to do a rash i
mean yeah so you could try to follow the
same framework
and uh i would conclude by just pointing
out that i mean you know this
looking at this heuristic that i
presented uh i would like to know
personally if
if this cannot be leading to anywhere
and thank you very much
or all of the approximation results that
you're getting can be reproduced by
looking at conformal maps uh you know
like the for example the e to the
negative x thing
what you would get if you i don't know
took a log to map the circle to the
strip and then
pulled back the attention of polynomials
or so i think uh
intart once suggested such a thing right
so i it doesn't work actually we tried
it
uh it doesn't work for your challenger
it works for many things but it doesn't
really work for this uh
does it work like does it give an
explicit answer to negative x
i don't think so
well thanks again thank you